اسابيع مرت على بدء النزاع المسلح وما
يزال السودان يعيش في حلقه مفرغه قتال ثم
مفاوضات تليها هدنه مؤقته لا تنال ثقه
الطرفين لتكسر من جديد شوارع الخرطوم
وبحري واندرمان تحولت الى فتنه عسكريه
وساحه قتال مع اصرار الطرفين على تحقيق
النصر لكن محاولات احلال السلام لا تزال
موجوده اليوم اعلنت الخارجيه السعوديه
توصل الطرفين لاتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
لاربعه وعشرين ساعه يبدا صباح غدا السبت
ماذا ان لم يلتزم الطرفان النتيجه ستكون
تاجيل محددات جد
حققنا بعض النجاح لم يكن نجاحا كاملا لان
الاطراف لم يلتزموا التزاما كاملا ونستمر
في العمل لبحث السبل لرفع المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني عن طريق الوصول الى
تفاهمات معينه مع الاطراف هناك بوادر
ايجابيه حتى اليوم في المحادثات قد نصل
الى هدنه اخرى مع اليات مراقبه اكثر تشددا
تساعدنا في تحديد مواطن
الخلل او المخالفه ان حصل ذلك وان التزم
الاطراف سيكون ذلك بصيص امل جديد لاخواننا
في السودان وهنا اوجه كلامي مره اخرى الى
الاشقاء في السودان كافه ان الدم السوداني
غالي وان لابد ان نعمل جميعا على
معالجه هذه الازمه بالحوار وعيدا عن
السلاح لان السلاح لا يحل شيء ولن يفضي
الى نتيجه سواء مزيد من الدمار ومسيد من
الابرياء يسقطون
جهود وقف في اطلاق النار السعوديه
الامريكيه تاتي مع جهود اخرى امميه بقياده
المبعوث الاممي
قبل ايام مدد له مجلس الامن الدولي المهمه
السياسيه لمده سته اشهر لكن هناك في
السودان من يعتبره سبب الحرب جبهه الجيش
السوداني الخارجيه السودانيه وصفت بالشخص
غير المرغوبه فيه لماذا الاجابه في رساله
وجهها البرهان الى الامم المتحده في اواخر
مايو الماضي
البرهان حينها بالمساهمه بسلوكه المنحاز
واسلوبه المضلل في اندلاع النزاع وباصراره
على فرضه الاتفاق الايطالي بوسائل واساليب
غير امينه كل هذا بحسب الرساله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات